تحاول فاطمه المساعده في اعمال المنزل بعد
ان تعافت من ورم سرطاني افقدها احدى
ساقيها عانت الفتاه اشهرا في ظل عدم توفر
العلاج في منطقتها بمحافظه حجه فاضطرت الى
الانتقال عبر البحر لتلقي العلاج في تعز
رح نتعزل ان هناك خرجنا عبر البحر واحنا
خايفين صدقنا ناصر من الريح من المطر
وصلنا هناك وانا حامل خرجنا البحر
ابونا جلسنا 17 يوم فحوصات واشعاعات في
الملف لما صدقنا احنا الملف يدخل المستشفى
تجربه حامد لم تكن افضل اصيب بجرح في قدمه
اثر حاجته دراجه ناريه فتحول الجرح الى
ورم سرطانين اضطره الى السفر بحرا للعلاج
في تعز
والبحر تعب وخوفه وبهذله لكن
واكتشفوه انه سرطان
فقرروا لها بثر
وحسب مسؤولنا في المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره
الحكومه اليمنيه في حجه فان السماح للمرضى
بالسفر عبر البحر له مبرراته
اضطررنا انه سفرهم من البحر
لانه لا يسمح لهم بالخروج من المنفذ
الوديعه بريا الان
ابلغنا من الحكومه مثلا بوزاره الصحه
مشكورين بوجود منح علاجيه ولكن
ولكن يشتوا وثائق رسميه زي الجوازات والله
في امان الله
تبدا الرحله البحريه لمرضى السرطان وذوي
الاعاقه بسبب الالغام من ميناء ميدي
بمحافظه حجه على البحر الاحمر وتستغرق
ساعات طويله وصولا الى ساحل المخا التابع
لمحافظه تعز جنوبي البلاد
اخيرا يصلون الى مبتغاه
يتوجه مرضى السرطان منهم الى المركز
الوحيد لعلاج الاورام في تعز الذي يقدم
خدماته للمرضى من المحافظات الاخرى ايضا
رغم الحصار الذي تعانيه المدينه وشح
الامكانيات والادويه
مركز العمل لعلاج الاورام السرطانيه هو
المركز الوحيد في محافظه تعز ورغم صعوبه
الحصار ورغم صعوبه وصول
المستلزمات الطبيه الى محافظه تعز الا
اننا استقبلنا حالات كثيره من محافظات
اخرى مثل محافظه حقه تسلط اوضاع مرضى
السرطان في اليمن الضوء على قضيه الطرق
والمنافذ البريه المغلقه في وجه الحالات
الانسانيه والتي تحتاج الى علاج عاجل
ويطالب المرضى بفتحها لانقاذ حياتهم